woo you got it I know I know hit in the
lap be careful M you're tall watch out
for the boom up
there hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Carmelo Anthony
he's one of the greatest scores in NBA
history a 10 time Allstar and three-time
Olympic gold medalist Vin the seventh
estate is his Global wine brand and he
has a brand new weekly talk show set to
launch on December 7th called 7:00 p.m.
in Brooklyn co-hosted by longtime friend
of the brand the kid Maro we're excited
for that Carmelo Anthony welcome to the
show yes yes yes how are you around
spicy food before we get started I'm all
right we we going to figure it out as we
go I'm good I'm usually good with spicy
food I I eat a lot of spicy food and you
know I like to dip and dab and see
what's really hot so today I guess we'll
find out what's really hot I hope so I
hope so
[Music]
okay got eat the whole Wing you know I
go wherever you go in this whole thing
but usually just we going to S slow yeah
let's start slow and then if we're
feeling confident we can build from
there all right I like
[Music]
that that was a little light yeah there
we go little light so when I heard that
you were launching a show at the kid
Merill my first and immediate thought
was that makes total sense do you
remember the first time that you were
introduced to him or his work and then
why' you think you gel well together on
a show it was the it was the culture it
was how he did it it was how they did it
um you know they was over that advice I
was in the you know been I was around
advice at that time and just seeing them
how they was operating and seeing how he
was moving and kind of just setting a
precedent for a lot of shows and and
content that that that we see today Mar
is an illustrious hot ones Alum we
actually reached out with him to see if
he could help us in preparing this
interview and he went above and beyond
actually sending a video question for
you here on Wing one so if you look at
the monitor here's the kid Maro with a
very important question for Carmelo
Anthony yo Melo what's up it's your boy
kid Mero the human durag flap I'm here
I'm trying to get like you bro I'm
trying to fill up this wine Salo with
some fine Veno but check it out I got a
question for you B what is the official
leather of dudes like us oh you know the
answer I'm a Pelle guy it was just the
swag it was the leather it was the aura
that you you know that you exuded when
you had a Pelle on
[Music]
that's actually a really good win so you
can go back and go for a bite another
bite I'm going in just cuz I'm kind of
enjoying it you know
mhm from the wreck to Mount Royal to
court 77 which basketball court of your
youth was the most significant in
shaping you as a player you think I
would say the 77 Court once you got in
that cage it wasn't you had to get
yourself out of that and it wasn't
no ages you know you you was 8 10 12
playing with the older people older guys
that was out there so you had to be
different you had to be you had to be
very different uh to survive that
basketball court what would you say
distinguishes somebody who grew up
playing in Baltimore versus someone who
grew up playing in New York or DC well
it just it's a mindset I think
everywhere's a mindset but you know as
far as Baltimore you know we always felt
it was overshadow you know you you in
between DC New York Philly and you know
it's kind of just skip over Baltimore so
we always had that that edginess that
that chip that we our backs against the
wall at every moment and then during
your senior year at Oak Hill I'm curious
which was a sweeter win for you was it
beating LeBron St Vincent St Mary's team
on National Television or was it coming
back to Baltimore to beat your old
school toson Catholic oh these are good
questions man
um I would say coming
back coming back cuz that was like the
ending it didn't end well when I was in
Baltimore being able to come back and
play against my for you know my my
former team like game evolving you know
at that moment it was like I really want
to come back to play my old school but
also to bring it back to Baltimore city
as a
whole n we do three for three so far
there we
go when Jimmy Butler was on the show he
told this story about how you guys are
on a night out in Italy and that you
stole a bottle of 2004 petruse from the
table before anyone else got a chance to
try it confirm or deny did he use the
word stole that's that's yeah yeah we
could check the tape but he was like
excited to try it and then all of a
sudden tell you why I stole no well I'm
just I I'm open to the clarification
give you what happened and then you tell
me if I stole it or not okay all right
all right they're at dinner they're
already at a wine dinner mhm
right I come a little late so I feel bad
I'm late I know the restaurant so I say
I'm going go downstairs to the Sellar
I'mma grab some bottles and I'mma here's
what we going to do tonight I go grab
the bottles and I grab the bottle of
puse and I I bring it to the
table they was drinking everything else
and left the petruse there at the end of
the night closed so we was leaving I
grabbed the
petruse no one knew I had the petruse
right they thought we had already drank
the petruse there was just so much wine
going on so you don't think that they
could have possibly been like saving the
petruse you know 2004 bottle of petruse
that's a very special wine you don't
think that maybe they were saving it
told I told them in the car
on the picture I sent them the picture
with me on the
one you know but it was you know they
wasn't ready for the petruse at that
moment right right so had that yeah I
had to preserve
[Music]
that I see hot ones stamped a couple of
these okay I see the r we about to go
down after this one so I'm going put
that one down yeah that's that's good
yeah got the intended effect I see what
we about to do
here I have this memory of you in the
2008 Olympics in Beijing holding this
fullon Sony camcorder yeah two questions
why and then two do you still have the
footage I still have the footage yes um
I just I understood moments you know I
just understood like this is this is a
moment the greatest athletes in every
sport is in one place for me I was
trying to see everything of the three
gold medals that you have which one has
the most significance to you I would say
2008 because prior to 2008 we lost in
the Olympics in ' 04 we lost in ' 06 in
the world
championship and 08 was kind of that
that redeem moment get right you got to
get
[Music]
right I see the M this one's a jump
right here that's a leap
mhm that's a leap you got more questions
I got you I got
you is it true that you once in
conversations with Spider-Man creator
Stan Lee about creating a DVD comic
where you'd play basketball by day and
fight crime at night you did some
research man cuz now people people don't
know that so yes you know and then you
know big shout out to you know recipes
of standard we had this conversation
years ago probably 03 04 I went to his
office and he's like I want to make you
a character he said I want to create
this character for you I don't know what
it is but I'mma I'm going let you know
what it is and he actually started doing
he created an actual comic book but I
can't find the [__] I don't
know I don't know where it's at but the
fact that and he reached out to me at
that point in time so yeah we was in the
works on you know working on I don't I
wouldn't say it was a Marvel you know
what I mean yeah yeah but that's amazing
yeah so you know the fact that we had
that conversation and and that's that's
more Priceless than to me than anything
else and then is it true that the wire
was shot in and based on your
neighborhood and that you'd casually
walk by that iconic orange couch just
like in your everyday life yeah that was
just you know you walk to school you see
that they filming you know it was just
everyday life casual oh I you know you
wondering what the cameras is over there
what they shooting why they shooting
you know you hear the back and forth of
get out of here from the from the people
that's actually living there to the the
actors and the set and yeah it was just
a lot but I mean it wasn't about that
neighborhood it was just shot in that
neighborhood but the story consisted of
guys and people that was connected to
those neighborhoods and then finally is
it true that Master P tried out for the
Denver Nuggets during your rookie year
and if so what if anything do you
remember about that that's a fact Master
Peach Yes master Peete tried out for the
Denver Nuggets we actually had a little
cool relationship man doing pre-season
training camp um you know used to pull
up in his limo to the practices and you
know he was Master PE right so that you
know he was the one of The Originals of
kind of making that transition over from
hip-hop to to sports and basketball in
particular so yeah he we he was out
there practice um I had Dennis Robin
there Sean KMP was there like I had
that's an insane rookie year yeah so it
was like everybody was just trying CR
was crazy that first
year I see the names are starting to get
you know they going from one to two to
three I appreciate you bringing wine by
the way yeah y'all was offering me
milk I might have had a wine
milk so I've heard you talking about
your time in Denver is not only building
a new team but also changing a culture
why was switching the Jersey from Navy
to baby blue why was that such a
symbolic moment in your eyes I just
think the intersection of
culture and sports and Hip-Hop and just
the fan base at at that point in time
and also the NBA was like it was just
looking for new energy and new
identities and you know when we came in
it was just like here's a perfect time
to do that one of my favorite throwback
jersey is Alex English number two right
Denver nuggets that's one of my
favorites I actually wore it it you just
felt it you felt like the like the
newness of of of Denver you felt the
organization was trying to go into
another direction did you live in the
same complex as the mascot Rocky I did I
did that was my man
that's Rocky was my man I lived in the
same we Liv in the same highrise as um
you know as as each other and I never
knew that was him you know used to do
the the back with was shot yeah yeah he
was known for that one day I'm after
practice think I was injured I come back
for treatment later on and I catch
him I catch him with
the I catch him with the helmet off and
I'm like oh I've seen you in the
elevator before you live in my building
he's like yeah I live with you I didn't
want to I didn't want to break the news
to you so yeah I lived in the building
with Rocky shout out to Rocky shout out
to
Rocky
this might be the setup Wing right here
it's actually the next one but this
one's not fun
either that ain't
bad it's
um got a little yeah and kind of like a
Time release thing you know yeah it got
that
uh like that Caribbean mhm like Sting to
it yeah that like a scotch Bonet kind of
yeah light you up like it's alive a
little bit it's a party yeah do you have
a lay person friendly explanation for
what made you such a great rebounder you
know your commitment to getting boards I
think that's one thing that your critics
they don't give you enough credit for I
appreciate that I always wanted to make
the game fun right so I always was told
at at your position which is a small
forward 68 you have to
be one of the best rebound is at that
position so I always enjoyed like
rebounding like it was just fun I always
enjoyed it and then I used to I used to
watch you know guys like Moses Malone
and how he used to you know throw the
ball back to himself to Pat his stats
like so I used to I used to so I learned
all of that like how to get fouled you
know to get my rebound back so I learned
little pieces of the game um it really
kicked in on the USA team we got 10 12
Hall of Famers on one team I can't do
what I do in New York and in Denver I'm
going go to make this game fun I want to
I want to break Charles Barkley
rebounding record and that's that's
where the rebounder kind of just got it
that tenacity and you know [__] out of
here it's
like so all of those started to come
into play so yes rebounding has always
been like fun for
me Beyond Insanity you're not supposed
to eat that
you you can smell it yeah it'll be
immediate
[Music]
yeah oh [__] yeah nothing fun about
that oh
[__] all right here we go and it kind of
doesn't stop you know it just keeps
growing pause
but I have to say Melo incredible
composure from your side of the table
over here that's I think you're doing
better at this than I am yeah no
problem
woo oh
[__] and then be careful be careful yeah
am I got you all right all right I'm
just checking on you just
checking ah do you have a favorite
mellow lyric of all time you have unique
distinction of being named check by popm
Smoke by Lil Wayne and
[Music]
Beyonce this thing got be crying I know
I know me too I ain't sh it 10 so
long
woo fabulous had a great a great one he
said something like coming through the
Thunder must have been hoodie mellow you
know on the Freddy and Jason released
that him and Jay kiss there so that was
actually another one you know long
damn I'm crying because of the the hot
sauce not because of the song
Sentimental right no but it could be
just yeah be sentimental but it is
sentimental temp nah that was a that was
another one like that that that I don't
think gets enough a lot of credit nor
the righty to that all right how are you
doing I'm good I I got my second win but
you I see you tearing up over there
we're both crying here table is a very
sentimental it's a it's a the wings that
can hit you right in the heart sometimes
I knew I knew some was crazy with that
one though are you ready to move on to
the next one you want to ask another
question first or you want to go to the
next
one here's what the good are you
competing with me cuz I se I haven't
seen you I'm not competing I'm if
anything I'm just a a support system
like we're on the same team we're in the
same we're in the same backt over here
all right TR not to hit you know go over
there I saw that you haven't touched uh
you haven't touched any beverage so far
it's all good respect respect all right
so this next one is the zuu 7
pot it will not be as bad as the last
one no I'm waiting on you you go first
all
right taking it down living to tell the
tale over
[Music]
here
I see how you I see the setup though
don't I see the setup not bad but right
I wasn't lying I wasn't lying to you no
I
bet so the Big East has always been
Larger than Life but especially during
your era where does going undefeated in
the Carrier Dome rank on your list of
career accomplishments top top top it's
it's it's hard to do and and I'm glad
you asked that question because it it
doesn't get enough attention to that
either to go into a place like s shes go
17 and0 in the Carrier Dome and never
lost I mean the championship was was
great but that's that's that's special
to know that you did that you know you
took care home do you remember what
coach beay heim's reaction was initially
when after you won the National
Championship you were talking about
staying at Syracuse so that you could
keep you know having fun and being the
big on Camp thought was
bugger is that what he said you bugger
no he didn't say that told me to you
know said it in other ways in bayam
language but I think at the time people
saw more in me than I did in myself it
was just like I'm just going to do this
all right man we won all right cool on
to the next what's what's next what's
the next thing I wasn't looking like in
the future and trying to see what's
going on it was like what's the what's
next all right
[Music]
Carmelo this one cl is a brand new one
so I don't want to break the seal so
don't worry about it you want this one I
got to reach too far don't yeah don't
need don't need don't need worry about
[Music]
it
yeah you know what it's all over we've
reached the top of the hot sauce
Mountain talked about your legendary
basketball
career touched on the wine
business
your new show you got it you got it I
know I know hit in the lap be careful M
you tall watch out for the boom up
there all but to close things out I want
to highlight your appreciation an
impressive collection of installation
art that you recently showed off on the
ad home tour so to close things out
which painting on your walls inspires
you the most which one is the most
divisive when you have guests over and
then what would be the first one you'd
grab if your house is on fire and you
needed to save one piece of art
oh the
conversation started would
be the Daniel Mary
Quinn people walk around they see that
it's like oh explain that to me please I
have a couple South African artist Nel
Momo they watching us you know I think
it's four or five kids on there and they
all kind of different expressions and
point looking at different ways and it's
like they looking out into the world I
have a Ernie Barnes for me it's special
cuz you get a you get a chance to talk
about an athlete doing something
different you know going to painting
going to do art and you know not being
pigeon ho hold into one kind of genre
well you know what Carmel Anthony your
performance today a masterpiece and now
good though it was only one it was one
that got me it was one well you know
what you don't have to worry about that
it was beyond
Insanity no shame in that and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
listen man we got a new talk show coming
out um 700 p.m. in Brooklyn uh co-hosted
by the kid Miro that's going to be fire
all my all my fans all my wine lovers
out there we got a whole bunch of
releases of wine coming out but yeah
show was popping hot ones is
hot you know in the bomb Beyond
Insanity woo so that's the hot ones
experience y'all are bugging with these
Wings did the research huh you got good
research team over
here hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and TI the season to
turn up the heat with our hot ones 10
pack that's right the hot ones 10pack a
legendary lineup with two brand new
sauces bookending it on either side we
have the hot ones classic Buffalo as
well as the last dab experience made
with the new Guinness World Records
hottest chili pepper X that's
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the Season 22 10
pack TI the season to turn up the heat